[Music]
on this Sunday night the big-spending
picture Canada's ballooning deficit stop
hiding the mess how long before we get
out of the red the bat is going to take
many many years and get the economy back
on track
the whu-oh reports a record rise in
kovat 19 cases plus the summer rain and
the snowmelt raised red flags and the
pubs open in the UK but Brits aren't
minding the social distancing gap
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us it's a big week ahead for the
nation's pocketbook the federal
government is finally preparing its
first fiscal update since the global
pandemic began Ottawa went into this
health crisis in the red and that
deficit will be bigger we're learning
that recipients of old age security and
the guaranteed income supplement will
see a one-time boost in the coming days
but the federal government has been
spending on other Canadians and
businesses as well to keep the economy
afloat our chief political correspondent
David akin breaks down the political
calculus of the government's financial
plan for many seniors keeping safe
during this pandemic has come with
additional costs a switch from public
transit to taxis delivery of food
instead of grocery store trips increased
visits to the pharmacy
we saw seniors facing an increased costs
as a result of the the covert 19mm death
pandemic and we wanted to support them
in those additional costs and this is
the week that that support will arrive a
one-time payment for those receiving old
age security of $300
guaranteed income supplement recipients
will get an additional $200 and it will
be automatic seniors should hang up on
anyone who phones them up with offers to
apply for this money don't fall you know
pray to those that may be calling
telling you you need to reveal some
information to get the money it's coming
automatically and it's tax-free but help
for seniors and for everyone hit by the
pandemic is taking a huge toll on the
federal treasury payments to seniors 2.5
billion dollars the Canada emergency
student benefit 5.9 billion dollars the
emergency wage subsidy estimated 56
billion and then there's the Serb it's
the big one
the Canada Emergency Response benefit
likely to cost 71 billion dollars those
plus other programs mean the deficit
could clock in at 256 billion dollars on
Wednesday Parliament will reconvene so
Finance Minister Bill Morneau can
provide some details on those numbers
and what the government is calling a
fiscal snapshot conservatives say it's a
fiscal selfie
tinged with red ink we need the
government to tell us next week how big
is the deficit how big is the debt stop
hiding the mess experts say one thing is
for certain there is no quick fix for
this mess that is gonna take many many
years it might be upwards of a decade
before they get the deficit eliminated
and start paying down the debt
conservatives also want more money for
the auditor-general they say the number
of audits has been halved over the last
decade even as government spending has
doubled and that's because the Auditor
General's budget has not kept pace and
in a minority Parliament a commitment to
more oversight is the least the
governing liberals should expect if they
want the opposition to support their
spending programs Robin David nickens in
Ottawa thanks David the only way to
kick-start economies is by opening up
and but but by doing that there's a
bigger risk of contracting the virus on
Prince Edward Island which hadn't had a
case since late April five people have
now tested positive the province
recorded two new cases today their close
contacts of one of three new cases
reported Saturday it's the first week of
the Atlantic travel bubble the new cases
aren't connected to that the provinces
chief Public Health Officer says it is
conducting contact tracing and right now
there's no indication of an increased
risk but to remain vigilant we are
experiencing a cluster of four cases
that appear to be related to travel to
Nova Scotia and contact with an
individual who had recently arrived from
the United States but this cluster of
cases is a clear reminder that Cova 19
is still very much present in our
province and we must remain vigilant in
the coming weeks Canada's public health
officials hope to get a better picture
of the actual rate of infection in this
country 40,000 blood samples collected
since May are now being tested for kovat
19 antibodies these tests can determine
how many Canadians have been infected
more than a hundred and five thousand
people in this country have tested
positive since January but experts say
that number could be ten to twenty times
higher because not everyone has been
tested and not everyone shows symptoms
the Siksika first nation in southern
Alberta has imposed a curfew as it tries
to contain a Cova 19 outbreak there are
currently 11 active cases of Cova 19 on
the Siksika first nation health
officials there say they are monitoring
287 people for symptoms the curfew aimed
at stopping the spread of the virus
begins at at 11:00 p.m. tonight and ends
at 5:00 a.m. daily truth Alberta doesn't
help by you know lifting these
gatherings to 200 you know our people
are used to our gatherings our family
gatherings you know our traditional
gatherings and so forth so once that not
with a you know our people here that
number you know they think everything's
okay but it's not okay the First Nation
is an active talks with the provinces
health services and federal indigenous
relations Minister Mark Miller about
funding shortfalls to fight the pandemic
the United States still has the most
infections and deaths there are 2.8
million cases in that country and nearly
a hundred and thirty thousand people
have died and tonight
experts are already warning of a second
wave that's because of the many people
who attended Trump reelection rallies
where no masks were required and there
was little social distancing here's
Jennifer Johnson the White House lit up
in red white and blue as Americans
celebrate the country's independence US
President Donald Trump ignoring health
experts warnings about large gatherings
addressed a crowd in Washington Koba 19
cases are surging in over 30 states but
the president is predicting a quick
resolution to the pandemic we are
unleashing our nation's scientific
brilliance and will likely have a
therapeutic and or vaccine solution long
before the end of the year this holiday
has looked very different some beaches
closed others packed with people
desperate to get back to normal life the
governor of New Jersey once part of
three states that were the epicenter of
the virus is worried about a new wave of
cases we're starting to see a small
spikes and reinfection from folks coming
back from
places like Myrtle Beach and and as well
as in Florida other hotspots to me it
says we need a national strategy we're
only as strong as our weakest link right
now new cases of the virus are breaking
records almost daily in Florida Arizona
California and Texas a month ago one in
ten people were testing positive today
is one in four President Trump says 99%
of COBIT 19 cases are totally harmless
but his own medical experts refused to
defend that unfounded claim I'm not
going to get into who's right and who's
wrong we have data in the White House
Task Force those data show us that this
is a serious problem the pandemic isn't
the only problem the president is facing
right now there are reports Trump was
briefed in February about a suspected
Russian bounty program paying the
Taliban to kill US soldiers in
Afghanistan the president the United
States has demonstrated absolutely
callous disregard for the safety and
security of American forces in a war
zone several members of Congress both
Republicans and Democrats are demanding
an investigation the House Committee on
Foreign Affairs will grill Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo on the allegations
this week Jennifer Johnson Global News
Washington
in the UK a country hit hard by the
pandemic the lockdown is easing and pubs
considered a social institution in that
part of the world have reopened but
rules requiring people to stay apart
weren't always respected when lifting a
pint and as Redman Shannon reports the
head of England's police union says it's
crystal clear that drunk people and
distancing don't mix after more than
three months of lockdown and isolation
England was ready to let loose the
government chose to relaxed rules
starting on the weekend something police
did not support
in some places like central London pub
bores spilled out onto the streets and
as the evening wore on physical
distancing was no longer a priority from
what I've seen although there's some
pictures to the country very very
largely people have acted responsibly
and my overriding message to people is
yes enjoy the new freedoms but do so
safely following social distancing the
chair of England's police union was less
diplomatic tweeting what was
crystal-clear is that drunk people can't
or won't
socially distance a mixed reaction to
from Londoners enjoying the afternoon
after I mean I'm actually not surprised
I mean like I think people have been
around too long there was no social
distancing there's no two meters at all
it seems like everyone's just decided
that the pandemic is over and we're back
to normal
so yeah slightly worrying but when it
comes to spreading covered 19 evidence
suggests that being outside is nowhere
near as risky as being inside which
means the real problems could arise when
the weather gets cold and drinking
outside is less enticing and the whole
idea of the bar is for people to be
socializing and mingling and you had the
alcohol factored into that in editions
go down I think it's sort of in a way a
perfect storm this infectious disease
expert says a covert 19 vaccine or
treatments are key to getting life back
to normal so I wouldn't feel comfortable
going into an indoor bar tape setting
for quite a while I think until we have
those tools at our disposal just like
Canada different parts of the UK are
reopening at different times so Wales
and Scotland will be looking closely at
how Saturday night affects the pandemic
in England Redman Shannon Global News
London
in Australia thousands of people living
in public housing are now under a strict
lockdown as infection spiked in
Melbourne that country's second largest
city police are patrolling the
surrounding streets and corridors as
three thousand people living in nine
public housing blocks believed to be the
center of the outbreak are now locked
inside their apartments for at least the
next five days that could be extended if
residents refused to be tested for Cova
19
Mexico has become one of the global
covered 19 hotspots with a rapidly
rising number of deaths at 30,000 deaths
it now has the fifth highest number of
deaths in the world but the government
believes the actual number of deaths
could be nearly double the official
count there have been two hundred and
fifty two thousand confirmed cases of
Kovan 19 in the country in the country's
capital which has by far the most cases
city officials ordered non-essential
businesses to close for the weekend
stores had recently reopened but failed
to take proper steps to prevent the
spread of the virus India reported its
highest single day increase in new cases
today nearly 25,000 in the past 24 hours
in New Delhi the government opened the
world's largest temporary hospital with
more than 10,000 beds to treat Cova 19
patients as new infections rise
officials pushed back plans to reopen
popular tourist attractions like the Taj
Mahal which was set to open on Monday
coming up the flood warnings in BC and
one communities drinking water is wiped
out
it was a stormy summer day in
Saskatchewan yesterday Environment
Canada confirmed at least three
tornadoes in the southwestern part of
the province as severe thunderstorms
moved through the region one twister
touched down near the town of Glen Bane
that's about 220 kilometers south of
Regina several rural communities in the
south were under tornado warnings until
about 8 p.m. local time people in
British Columbia have their eyes on
water levels flood warnings and watches
are in place throughout much of the
province in Cache Creek about 80
kilometres west of Kamloops dozens of
homes are under evacuation alerts
that's where Global's Paul Johnson is
tonight Paul what's the situation on the
ground there Robin this is the Bonaparte
River it cuts right through the middle
of cash Creek take a look at it right
now you can see the water is very high
and fast and it's eroded its bank
substantially there are at least 160
properties here in Cache Creek that are
under evacuation alert so far
authorities here feel like they're
holding their own right now and if the
water doesn't get much beyond the
expected high-water mark that they think
is going to happen later this afternoon
they think they're going to be okay
but there's rain in the forecast for the
headwaters of the Bonaparte River if
things do worse in here and get
dangerous they are prepared to go from
an evacuation alert through an
evacuation or the emergency support
services people will give them
accommodations and meals for the next
few days however long it takes and we
have several local motels that will put
them up and restaurants that will feed
them across BC still a number of trouble
spots connected to high water and
flooding there are about five hundred
people with no drinking water right now
in the Seymour arm community in the
Shuswap area after a mudslide there
people living near the quenelle River
are watching the waters their closely
and of course the Fraser River BC's
biggest just east of Vancouver in the
Lower Mainland is very high right now
and authorities
watching it closely and warning people
to stay away from its banks that's the
latest from here in Cache Creek now back
to you Robin all right thanks for that
Paul tensions were high today in st.
John's Newfoundland with some residents
being asked to shelter in place for
several hours police responded to
reports of what they called unknown
trouble just after 4:00 this morning and
found a man dead the road was closed in
a shelter-in-place order remained until
just after 5:30 this evening
investigators are still on the scene and
canvassing the neighborhood for
information still ahead why are
Canadians with cystic fibrosis being
kept away from life-saving treatment
you are watching global national it is
estimated that one in every 3,600
children born in Canada has cystic
fibrosis and there's no cure there have
been recent advancements in treatment
that can improve the chances of survival
but as Dan Spector explains Canadians
can't access it yeah just trying to save
my life
Montreal's Chelsea Gallo may look like a
healthy 31 year old woman at first
glance but every single day she's
fighting just to breathe last month
I actually started coughing up blood
Gallo lives with cystic fibrosis a
genetic disorder that attacks the
respiratory system
she takes dozens of pills per day uses
this machine to loosen up the mucus that
accumulates in her lungs but it's still
getting worse you know each year you get
more sick treatments are emerging drugs
like or can be have improved quality of
life for CF patients during trials in
Ontario but another medication is
creating even more optimism try CAFTA a
combination of three drugs created by
American pharma company vertex it's
really as close to a miracle drug as you
could get in the US try CAPTA was
greenlit by the fda last fall
just this week it came to the UK NHS has
just landed the deal to deliver the
life-saving cystic fibrosis drug trike
after cystic fibrosis patients there
were overjoyed if everything but Daniel
and thousands of other Canadians have
not experienced that joy the drug is not
on the market here I'm like scared at
this point that I'll pass away before I
get it behind one Chelsea you have
thousands of CS families that are really
frustrated because this drug TriCaster
really it is game-changing like other
cystic fibrosis drugs try CAFTA can cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars per
year per patient health canada does
allow Canadian patients to apply for
medications like Trek CAFTA via the
special access program and to date 122
Canadians have been given access but not
everyone is a
proved to gang yyl that's not enough
it's really like we're in the middle of
this tug of war and we're the ones who
are suffering Health Canada says it has
been in talks with vertex since 2019 but
the company has not applied to market
the drug in Canada yet
advocates say new government regulations
are scaring them away and you need to
create that fine balance between
attraction at the between attracting
innovative treatments and respecting
your payment capacity Health Canada told
Global News to improve access to these
medicines for Canadians we've made
changes to the rules regulating the
maximum prices of patented medicines
just they put all these hurdles in which
are harmful to the rare disease
community
Chelsea hopes everyone who needs try
CAFTA will be able to access it sooner
rather than later and be able to feel
this kind of happiness Dan Specter
Global News much Rio up next young dog
new tricks why this Calgary canine is
going viral it may have been an American
holiday last night but Canadians living
near the American border enjoyed some
4th of July fireworks as their southern
neighbors celebrated that wasn't last
night's only treat Skywalkers also
enjoyed a buck moon partial eclipse the
rare lunar event saw a full moon
slightly dim by a bit of Earth shadow
adding a little drama to last night's
festivities at just two and a half years
old a Calgary dog is taking social media
by storm Milo has garnered thousands of
fans around the world after a few videos
of his masterful tricks went viral as
Lauren Pollan reports his owner says
it's all aimed at spreading joy
thank you if those unassuming baby blues
didn't already do the trick catch
two-and-a-half-year-old milo in action
[Applause]
and it's pretty hard not to stop and
stare they'll grab you a bottle of coke
out of the refrigerator he'll jump into
a tree he'll jump over a fence for you
the border collie Australian Shepherd
grabs all sorts of attention at this
Calgary dog park it's pretty amazing
it's got some serious talent and that
challenge is now being seen around the
globe we've had oh gosh I think over 80
viral videos now it's been absolutely
nuts showing off his smarts he's super
cute all these videos on Instagram are
awesome some 95 tricks and Counting I
work with this guy for probably about
two to three hours a day
Jessica Gardiner doesn't do it for the
fame I figure you know they bring me so
much joy why not share a little bit of
that with people that are going through
some very difficult and uncertain times
right now she started her journey as a
dog trainer in 2016 with her first
rescue pup shadow who holds an
incredibly special place in her heart I
had actually gotten her for a very
special reason I had actually lost my
son I lost my son at about 35 weeks into
my pregnancy and it was really really
hard on us you know and I turned to my
husband I remember telling him I need
something I need something to help me
cope my guys have pulled me through a
lot now a mom of two her kids are
already taking a page out of mom's
training book the family has recently
expanded by four more legs sure to
inspire even more internet love we can't
control everything that's happening
around us but you know we can control
the little smiles and stuff that we can
bring to people's faces right and from
right here in Calgary and they're
spreading smiles that stretch around the
world
good boy Milo good job buddy Lauren
Poland global news and that is global
national for this Sunday I'm Robin Gill
tonight your Canada is the lower for
Kerry national historic site in Manitoba
thank you for watching
Donna Friesen we'll be here tomorrow
have a good night
[Music]